conjure an image of the russian tundra
siberia
as far north as you can go before you
hit the arctic ocean
your image probably looks like a snowy
whiteout
you might picture stark forbidding ice
scapes devoid of color and life
but through the lens of national
geographic explorer and photographer
evgeny arbogyva it's a wonderland
wrestling with people and their stories
like for example the keepers of the
remote weather stations that line
russia's arctic coast
when i was
a kid my dad would bring me to visit
meteorological station and i wanted to
be in all of them i just wanted to see
how how it is to live there so as an
adult she hopped on an icebreaker that
brought supplies to those isolated
outposts i saw this
station that was you know from the 30s
that haven't been renovated since then
and was all surrounded by sand and then
there is this
uh man comes out with his bright blue
eyes
total loner unable to kind of make
connections with people because he's
just too overwhelmed by all of us the
man's name was slava
he was in his 60s and he lived alone at
the weather station an hour's helicopter
ride from the nearest settlement
right away afghani was drawn to him
he was kind of trying to hide almost
from everyone
but i could tell that he is he is a real
thing he is of the arctic of the nature
so how did you
i mean if he's afraid of people or you
know
not good at making connections
how did you convince him to let you come
and spend time with him
well as they're unloading all the
supplies and all these people from
meteorological organizations they're
like okay slava you know give us the
charts blah blah blah all these things
and he's overwhelmed by all these
questions and i i'm there and i'm like
oh what's this and
what's this in the distance he's like
let's go i'll show you so he took me
just i think he was happy that to get
away from all these people
evgenia followed slava for a photo
series called weatherman
she captured the storm-battered wooden
cottage where he lives his lonely march
to log data in sub-freezing weather
and the antique looking radio that's one
of his few links to the outside world
i learned so much from him um
what i saw in him is this total honesty
about who he is and acceptance of
who he is
and also understanding the value of the
land
in the sense that he found the spot that
makes him happy
and he
he is this land so he managed to get
into the point where
he is
this sea and he is this peninsula as
much as he is lava
i'm peter gwyn editor-at-large at
national geographic and this is
overheard a show where we eavesdrop on
the wild conversations we have here at
nat geo and follow them to the edges of
our big weird beautiful world this week
why it's impossible for afghani arbor
guyva to look away from the arctic
she tells us about hunters looking for
the tusks of ancient mammoths melting
from the permafrost and about nomadic
reindeer herders following the rhythms
of their ancestors
and why this unique environment leaves
humans both odd and afraid
more after the break
evgenia's story starts on the edge of
siberia in a town called tixie
it's a small town on the shore of
laptifc in the russian arctic in the
republic of yakutia
and
when i was growing up there it was about
12 000 people living there so it was
pretty big it was a famous and important
seaport on the northern sea route
and during soviet time there were all
these people coming working there
military people scientists sea men and
it was quite a vibrant community
and then um
so i grew up there my parents were
teachers in in the high school
and
then after fall of soviet union
everybody just kind of it was this
massive wave of migration and we moved
to
the city called yakutskan which is the
capital of yakutia and officially the
coldest city inhabited by people
the coldest city inhabited by people yes
right now i just talked to my dad um
just now this morning he said it's minus
55. oh my gosh wow
celsius but tixi was it as cold as that
yeah it's not as cold as yakuza it's a
harsher climate because of the
the winds the winds are really strong
and blizzards sometimes last for a few
days and you just you literally cannot
even go out
from your house as a kid it was great
because you don't go to school
even snow days in the arctic yeah the
blizzard days we call it because you're
you you just you know if you're
especially if you're a small kid you
come out of the house and you literally
will be just flying in the tundra
uh because the winds are so strong so
tell me how you came to photography then
from tixi to yakuza
you know i know from working with
photographers the cold was not the
friend of the camera
so how did
when did that start
when i was 15 i was an exchange student
in in connecticut in the us
and i took photography class and
i was just blown away right away and
you know i
spent a lot of time in the dark room and
and then when they came back
to yakuza i thought okay i have to
continue
so i started working in the local
newspapers and
developing my film because there's not
much places to develop
i i was developing my film in in the
darkroom in the morgue
more because where you keep that dead
body
yeah wait a minute so you're developing
your pictures
in like a in the morgue of like the city
morgue of the hospital yes
yeah because i there was you know there
was not no places to develop film and
there is there was this guy who was
taking pictures of of dead people and
corpses in the hospital and he had this
dark room and so i was going there and
was developing my film
was that weird i mean was it was it
creepy um
i mean is there like a kid i was very
much focused on on developing my film
right right
so how did you take it to the next level
what what comes next uh then i
i went to study in moscow in
this moscow international university
i was studying management
art management and then
i went to travel with reindeer herders
and i was working um as a you know i was
living in with the reindeer herders
so how do you make that connection you
went from art management to reindeer
herding that was like there was a big
leap there in yakuza i mean it's you
know we're so close to um
indigenous cultures most of them are
nomads and reindeer headers
so i was aware of them and i was
photographing them at um the
celebrations that are happening in
yakuza
and also um a family of reindeer
critters or good family friend of of
ours so when i came back after
university
in moscow i just joined our friends and
i started migrating with them
and what does that look like what do you
mean the migration it's uh
well reindeer herders they have a herd
for of about 2000 reindeer and
some of them live in the tomb some of
them live in the tents
and they follow the the herd so they
migrate every depending on the season
they migrate every week or or or less
depending on if it's winter or summer
let's kind of skip ahead a little bit to
going back to tixie
how did that come about so after
living with reindeer herders at some
point i did start photographing because
it was just so amazing some things that
i saw there
and at that point i'm thinking okay this
is what i want to do
and i want to be a photographer
and
i go to new york to study photography in
international center of photography a
one year program
[Music]
and then i stay in new york for a little
bit and i'm being completely overwhelmed
by everything that is happening in new
york there's amazing art amazing artists
around the the the speed of the city i
love it uh and i hate it at the same
time as all new york
as all people who live in new york and
then i think okay i have to go back to
dixie i remember
that longing that i had all those years
and i thought to go and explore it
as a photographer this is how many years
later you're 19 years later okay
is this the first time you've been back
yeah it's first time i'm back since we
left what did i feel like
it felt so strange
yeah i had very strong emotions
especially because now
as i mentioned before
when i lived there there was 12 000
people
living in town and now it's only four
thousand so
the
most of majority of buildings in town
are abandoned so
it looks very scary and just
i was just really really sad i thought
that i'm not gonna take any pictures
because it's just too too sad to
to photograph
that's so
um ironic because the pictures that i've
seen that you took of dixie
are not sad
well my first trip after wandering this
empty street
um i went to the shore of the sea and i
was sitting there just kind of looking
at the horizon
and they saw a family um by the bonfire
and there was this girl who was just um
throwing stones in the water and they
were very quiet
and i could feel that there were in the
same emotional wavelength somehow
and
we started talking and
the more we started talking the more i
thought
this girl
she's still here she still has her
reality here in dixie how does she seize
the town
and
next trips
i came back and
i already
you know was following tanya this girl
and she
opened her vision of town to me which
was so similar to how i remember it so i
thought wow so it doesn't really matter
you know
if you love a place and if you're a kid
you don't see that that all this you
know ruins ruins start to be a
playground it becomes a haunted house
full of stories to explore
rather than a relic or a reminder of
fallen empire
what was it like to go to these places
with her
and you and you're seeing it through her
eyes but you're also
seeing it in your memory
because
my childhood in in tixi ended so
abruptly
so that it wasn't like
you know i was growing out of it it was
just like i had this beautiful world and
then i was taking away from it and and
so there was no closure and i was just
so happy to be with tanya
and to become a kid again um in this
place and
have enough time to play again
in the tundra and to run again
trying to touch aurora or things like
this and trying to touch a ruler yeah is
that a game that kids play in the arctic
oh yeah i want to play their games
or like making wishes
um
you know or like
digging hole in the tundra and putting
your wishes and writing your wishes and
putting your wishes in there hoping that
they will all come true and things like
this you know and because it was just me
and her and her friends and no adults
around i just was so free to be a kid
again as well what does the aurora
borealis look like in dixie it is a part
part of daily life i mean when i was a
kid and when tanya
was in txi
you just see aurora on your way to
school because in in winter it's polar
night so you don't see sun
at all for a few months
so you go to school and then you just
watch aurora what is it what does it
look like and it can be different uh it
can be just green
or just white or just yellow or it can
be
all kinds of colors purple yellow green
uh it depends it can be very different
can be a little bit it can completely
explode in the sky
and it's moving it's like shimmering and
moving across you or yeah it's moving
it's it's like this uh
it's alive
why is it important to you
to focus on the arctic right now i mean
i know you you come from the arctic and
you obviously have a deep love for it
but what are you thinking about right
now about you know the situation that
the arctic faces
oh there's so many things going on um
around the world but
in the arctic especially
mean i can not take pictures there now
you know it's just
there's just so many changes and so many
things that i
i i know they need to be photographed
now like
we used to
look at it with awe right now we're
looking at it and we're scared
are you scared
i'm both in awe and scared
so
one story that you work i think it may
have been your first story for national
geographic was looking at um the mammoth
tusks
and i think
in a way that story speaks to the
changes
in the arctic
that was such an
interesting sort of way to look at how
the climate is changing
yeah that was a
a very interesting um assignment and my
first one the story takes place in this
uh uninhabited islands and the in the
lab to see and
because of the erosion and permafrost
thought there is this mammoth tusks that
are
uh emerge from the land so these are
woolly mammoths that were living
in this region
and then like they're frozen there or
they how are the mammoths there i guess
is my question
well the mammoth used to live there and
then um
their carcasses and and their bones are
preserved so well because of permafrost
and because now permafrost is sowing
all these remains of mammoth come out
and and and
what happens
now is it becomes they call it like this
tusk rush so there is all this people
like a gold rush like a gold rush but
test crush yeah because
after the ban of uh international trade
of uh elephant ivory chinese market
needed to have a
replacement for the material so mammoth
now with emergence of all these mammoth
tusks in siberia this was this is now a
material that carvers are working with
and it's not illegal to use mammoth
tusks it's not yeah but there's it's a
gray kind of area still and
you know sometimes that we were
when we were digging out the
skull of a mammoth and you just i was
just standing there thinking wow this is
so scary what's going to happen because
we were also when when i was on the
bolshoi yakovsky and i had a gps and we
had an older map
so that was 2013
and i had a map of 2008 on my gps and i
was standing on the edge of the island
and the map of 2008 was showing that i'm
very much inland
and that's when i was just struck by the
difference
of the border of the edge of the island
because it had because it the permanent
road
yeah
yeah and some of the islands um
scientists predicted in my life in my
lifetime that won't be there anymore the
island will be gone yeah
so
what what's next what do you what do you
want to do next
i keep working i just finished three new
stories um
[Music]
in the arctic and these are in a way
that weatherman was the first chapter of
the stories and now i i produced three
more chapters
and i'll i'll be just keep
creating my necklace with different
beads and each story as a as a bead
um yeah i keep working in the arctic is
there any particular image that you just
can't get out of your head that you're
it would be your dream to photograph
well right now i'm really i really want
to
be able to find a way to photograph
tundra
in the in the way that
people could really see it because you
know tundra is just
as you know
in some areas they call it uh arctic
desert right so it's just very empty
space but it's not and
it's the a world of its own and and so
i'm struggling i'm trying to figure out
now how do i capture that tundra s space
it was a backdrop almost visually always
for
a story unfolding and now i really want
to focus on like this natural spaces
that are protagonists of their own
wow well
evgeny arburgaiva thank you very much
thank you so much
[Music]
to see more of afghania's work her
photos from tixie and her national
geographic stories about mammoth ivory
hunters and chasing rare butterflies in
malaysia check out the links in our show
notes
you can also find her photographs on our
instagram feed at nat geo and if guinea
is working on a new documentary set in a
region of siberia that features some of
the world's biggest gatherings of
walruses
you can find links for all of that in
the show notes they're right there in
your podcast app
if you like what you hear and you want
to support more content like this
please rate and review us on your
podcast app and consider a national
geographic subscription that's the best
way to support overheard and hear more
great stories go to natgeo.com
forward slash explore to subscribe
overheard at national geographic is
produced by brian gutierrez jacob pinter
marcy thompson and alana strauss our
senior editor is eli chen robert moleski
edited this episode
our senior producer is carl wills our
executive producer of audio's davar
arlen who produced this episode
our fact checkers are robin palmer and
julie beer michelle harris fact check
this episode
our copy editor is amy kulzak hansdale
seuss sound designed this episode and
composed our theme music
this podcast is a production of national
geographic partners
the national geographic society is
committed to illuminating and protecting
the wonder of our world and funds the
work of national geographic explorer
evgenia arbogyeva whitney johnson is the
director of visuals and immersive
experiences
and i'm your host peter gwynne thanks
for listening and see y'all next time
[Music]
you